all right border crossings
are booming but get a little bit of this
when it comes to
deportations well they're not
they're at a record low what kids chad
wolf is the former acting dhs secretary
um secretary i've never seen a chasm
like this in monthly data
what do you make of it
well neil what i will tell you is i'm
not sure that the numbers are all
together that surprising for those of us
that follow this
this is exactly what happens when you
tie the hands of law enforcement you're
going to see a rest go down
you're going to see removals or
deportations go down as well
so what the bite administration did in
really the early days of the
administration back in january
was to issue guidance to ice law
enforcement officials
really restricting them on who are the
types of individuals
that they can target for removal and so
now under that guidance you essentially
have to be a terrorist or a suspected
terrorist
or you have to be a convicted felon
aggravated felon
and so essentially that takes about 80
to 90 of
all of the targets off the table for ice
law enforcement officers
and so you see the result of that in the
data and the numbers that you just
showed
numbers and arrests and deportations are
down across the board
now what's odd about this there was a
time when barack obama was president
that
some groups were calling him the
deporter-in-chief and didn't like the
rate at which he was deporting those who
crossed the border or were just
at the border his vice president at the
time
supported that effort now he's president
united states but he is not
continuing that effort i wonder what you
make of that
well a couple of things and i think
what's most concerning is obviously we
see the situation going on at the border
not enforcing the rule of law on the
border
but now we are also seeing them not
enforcing the rule of law in the
interior of the united states right
these are individuals that ice comes
across
targets or comes into contact with
these are individuals that have no legal
right to remain here in the u.s and in
most cases they've gone
through a due process they've gone
before an immigration judge in most
cases
and they have been ordered to be removed
and so ice is effectuating that order
and for the bite administration and
officials at dhs to simply tell them to
ignore the law it puts law enforcement
officers in a very very
dicey situation where they have to
choose between their career
in following that advice or adhering to
the rule of law
and what they signed up to do to enforce
the law
we do know that the vice president alma
harris intends to go
uh to mexico elsewhere to to to get what
she says
is the start and and and what
causes this the root causes of this part
of that will involve giving
potentially billions to that neck of the
woods i'm talking beyond mexico but
central
america we don't know all the details
yet uh secretary but we know enough
a lot of money will be involved and i'm
just wondering whether that will do the
trick or you worry that it'll be good
money after bad
well i'm certainly concerned and i think
you you certainly need to put a number
of strings
attached to that funding you can't
simply provide it to them without any of
return on investment for the u.s and
that's what we did under the trump
administration we held them accountable
for doing and implementing the things
that they said they would do with that
funding
and at the end of the day we were able
to sign 12 14 different
security agreements with them but that
alone is not going to do it and so the
idea
and the strategy that i'm i'm i'm
looking at is
the bite administration is encouraging
mexico and the northern triangle to
do more to enforce their borders but yet
they are not
enforcing law on our southwest border on
our own border
and that's concerning that you're going
to continue to see
numbers that you saw in march and we see
in april continue to come across that
border if we don't
actually enforce the rule of law on that
border
you can do all you want you can you can
provide funding to the northern triangle
but if you're not going to hold people
accountable
those numbers are continued to come
all right chad wolfe thank you very much
the former acting dhs
secretary hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not gonna miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now